IT'S TIME FOR OUR NEXT GAME PUT
IT IN MY A-LIST.
THANKS TO THE INTERNET, THERE'S
NEVER BEEN A BETTER TIME TO BE
KINKY-- YOU CAN FIND OTHERS WITH
SIMILAR FETISHES, WATCH WEIRD
PORN, OR EVEN WATCH OTHERS
SEARCH FOR WEIRD PORN.
AWWW, BBW GRANNY BIG TITS.
I THINK IT'S TIME WE COME OUT
AND ADMIT THAT ALL OF US HAVE
SOMETHING WEIRD THAT GETS US
OFF-- EVEN CELEBRITIES.
SO COMEDIANS, I'M GOING TO SHOW
YOU A PICTURE OF SOMEONE FAMOUS,
AND I WANT YOU TO TELL ME WHAT
YOU THINK THEIR FETISH IS.
FIRST, DONALD TRUMP.
>> MEXICAN JUMPING ANAL BEADS.
Chris: POINTS.
>> Chris: NEXT, PAULA DEEN.
KEVIN.
>> SURPRISINGLY TOSSING SALAD.
>> Chris: NEXT, GRUMPY CAT.
DOUG.
>> TURNS OUT HE'S SUPER INTO
MONDAYS.
[LAUGHING]
>> Chris: NEXT, VLADIMIR PUTIN.
DOUG.
>> PUSSY RIOTS.
>> Chris: NEXT, KRIS JENNER.
>> HER KIDS SEX TAPES.
Chris: POINTS.
[LAUGHING]
>> Chris: NEXT, SPONGEBOB
SQUAREPANTS.
>> TAKING IT IN ALL OF HIS
HOLES.
>> Chris: POINTS.
ARE YOU SURE IT'S NOT WIPING UP
YOUR SQUIRTS.
AND FINALLY THE NICEST GUY IN
THE WORLD TOM HANKS.
>> GETTING T BAGGED BY WILSON.
NOT THE VOLLEYBALL HIS WIFE,
RITA WILSON.
>> Chris: SO WELL PLAYED.